hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
and today i've got a very special guest
who would like to interview
and this person has actually been on
many of my financial freedom challenges
and they're going to be able to give you
a special insight i thought it'd be a
great interview so welcome to the uh
welcome to the show okay the reason no
one's there
is because the guy i want to interview
is actually
a very special guest because he's the
guy that's
on the other side of the camera pav
videographer pav so i don't know how
we're going to do this
path could you maybe like leave the
cameras for a bit and come on the
oh my goodness let's try it let's try
the right side of the camera
goodness gracious um pav you've traveled
with me we've done multiple financial
freedom challenges how many
how many challenges have you done with
me um london evans london financial
freedom
evans and david in ireland
incredible the david ireland one is just
epic
and your footage and the reason i think
pav
is such a good videographer is because
he just
films everything you know
and i'll forget you there it's like fly
on the wall if we're if we're going into
an estate agent
you'll hold it down as if you're taking
pictures so you see black so i have to
take some pictures but then you'll just
keep it here
but you're actually secretly filming or
you'll get a gopro
if it's really secret like you even we
we even have like almost spy pens like
things
you're just the best secret videographer
ever
um why don't you give a little bit of
background as to who you are who is the
man behind the camera
and and then i'll maybe ask you some
questions and we can get a bit of an
insight for what it's like
being on the road traveling and and
different things so who is pav
path is the master spy cam as you said
even even when i was filming the
eviction as well the guys also noticed
that like
you know they're painting and they turn
like oh here is path you know like
i'm just coming out of nowhere yeah um
so my name is
pavel path shortly i remember the first
day in the office
uh you came i was like oh my gosh i'm
released i'm like hey wait my name is
pavel and you pop
pop pop pop pavel and then we had a
circle like to introduce the new guys
and we're like hey i'm popular you can
call me path and you and you jump in
like
oh my god why did you make me struggle
with your name
because you were like what and then when
you told everybody else you're like i'm
powerful oh thanks
thanks for yeah how long have you been
with
a couple years uh a year and a half
september it was one year
yeah so year and a half yeah stuff like
that um
okay cool so one of the things your
nickname we call you curious path
yeah curious pavel because you are
interested in stuff
um you were interested in property and i
think that's i think that's how you got
the
job in the first place because you've
been watching me a little bit i'm not
really sure
yeah i basically i like to ask questions
and uh
i when i don't know something i just ask
it i that that's how in a way the brand
camera
came along uh but it's so funny because
i was in the videography
field in london and i just got this job
as a because i knew somebody
who was in that in that case was rough
and it was so funny because i was
interested in property
way before i went to john lee's
trainings i went to bridge dance
training i went to a few other trainings
and i never heard about you but when i
started to research a bit more and i
just
just typed something properly on youtube
you came along and then two months after
that i was working for you it was
crazy and raph after we have to give
credit to raph because he linked us
together
top guy does a lot of videography work
for people like gary vaynerchuk and
warren buffett
so okay cool so started working i
remember the first time we ever worked
together it was a bit of a gamble when
london yeah right the first time what
happened so what happened was
it was probably it was my first week i
think it definitely my first week
uh and ralph was supposed to film the
challenge
but sarah comes in the office where the
video guys are and it's like oh guys you
know
we're supposed to film today but ralph
can't make it who wants to film and i
just look around everybody like you know
and i'm like i'll do it and sarah was
like really i mean you just started like
yeah i'll do it give me the challenge
and then i remember she came after that
and
she said that uh that she came to you
and it's like okay you know
path's gonna film you and you're like
yeah
yeah i didn't know i forgot i'd
forgotten
uh you you were so new and and you know
there was like maybe 40 members of staff
all around so
um six videographers um you know
some good times yeah yeah yeah
absolutely buzzing office in london now
everyone's working from home and
everything everything's a little bit
different but so so and i literally i'm
like right we're going to do a
financial freedom challenge which is 12
hours
to find a deal in london from scratch
um from your perspective
like is is is it as it seems because
people might watch the actual
documentary and think how much of this
might be maybe set up or maybe even
you know is this is this real life or is
this um
scripted you know and people sometimes
don't quite realize
um you're the videographer
tell us what it's like and what actually
happens what's the reality behind the
cameras
it's it's i mean if people think it's
scripted for them it's going to be
scripted i mean because it's
it's filmed and edited you can never be
sure but from my side it's it's really a
really
reality i mean i can say it's reality
i'm not sure people believe but it's
reality because
even when people were stopping you on
the streets we got that
not because we rehearsed it like oh can
we just do it again but because i was
filming everything as you said that's
how we got these things
so all these things it's reality and
it's really cool to see it
uh happening in front of yeah and even
like when we did the evans one
the whole thing with the apartment and
it it almost seems too good to be true
how easily
everything slots you know like like the
fact that the guy who
evans is like oh this is my dream
apartment and it just turns out that
the gut the agent is a fan of mine
and then when i get there and evans is
like this is my dream apartment and then
the guy was like oh samuel
it feels like this
almost people are gonna think this is a
freaking staged set up thing
you know but but it really isn't what
can you do you cannot do anything more
if if i didn't film that when he came
like oh you're just having leads
then if we need to repeat it his
reaction was gonna be the same
yeah most people would you know be
difficult to act anyway yeah
so and all of the deals like you know
the island one
i j you tell me this did i even
hand on heart know that we were outside
of the uk when we got to david's house
this guy doesn't know what's in his
travel bag
let alone where is he traveling it's
true man
i don't remember we were going we're
going we were flying with emilia
somewhere
and we we passed security and we're
walking
to the gate and you're like oh where's
my suitcase so that
they hold your suitcase to check stuff
in it then you just completely forgot
you left you're just walking like oh
where's my suitcase oh
you need to go back yeah i'm with the
financial freedom challenges a lot i
usually don't know that they're coming
until a couple days before anyway you
know i know that it's coming in the
background
yeah but i don't know when i'm gonna be
free so it's like
all right i've promised i'm gonna do a
financial freedom challenge with david
cool david i'll come at some point
he's messaging me puff what's happening
when you come in oh my god i don't know
and then it's like i'm like i'm pretty
i'm pretty free the next few days i've
got two appointments
i can probably cancel you know what pav
are you free tomorrow you're like that
that's the vibe though right
yeah usually it's like that you know
that's the vibe so
okay what is um what's been what's been
some of the highlights of of the
trips and stuff that we've done together
for me highlights is
i got to see the things happening
firsthand so
i get to see things that are not
mentioning videos like
little details about property stuff so
these are the biggest highlight for me i
i learned
also one of the things i learned from
you is uh these
three questions are you earning are you
learning and are you enjoying yourself
and to be fair this is a really
win-win-win for me because
i'm learning new things mainly about
property
i'm enjoying myself because i meet new
people and i travel around
and i'm earning a bit as well absolutely
absolutely
and i mean we we pay our videographers
no it's really really decent a month
yeah it's decent amount we don't try and
pay the lowest we can you know we pay
very reasonable good salaries uh not
just to our videographers but to all of
our staff right i don't know for the
rest but yeah
um you've also written a book i did
what's that called it's called how to
talk to strangers what made you write
that book
it was pandemic times and i already had
an online course on that subject and i
was like
you know it's it's we weren't for long
and uh
i didn't have it i don't like to stay on
one spot for a long time and like
let's do something and i remember but
when i was in
in high school i had a friend who told
me like one day i'm gonna write a book
and i was thinking like
you need to write so many pages then you
need to look how are you gonna
distribute it where you're going to
place it it's so much work nowadays
you just write it on a word document and
you just
post it around you just upload it to
amazon and that's it they do the
marketing
i'm like why not so you can call
yourself an author really easily these
days
so you are an author yeah i'm writing a
second one which was like what's that
gonna be how to be happy
oh that's great yeah really important
topic stuff yeah because i think i have
a lot to share
i think i'm really genuinely happy
person i have a lot to share and
it's really not i think as you know
if you know something you know share it
with the world don't keep it to you
another question as well how does this
fit because sometimes people
um people think that i am anti-jobs
and i'm not i don't know i'm not
anti-jobs at all
in fact most millionaires have a job
so you know i'll say to my staff you
know hey how many jobs as long as you as
long as you enjoy it and as long as
you're paid decent
well especially if you've got
opportunities to to grow on there's a
problem having a job
you are sat behind the camera every
freaking week with someone on winners on
a wednesday
talking about how and then how i got out
of my job
yeah you go every week and you're behind
the camera
being employed having a job what's the
thought process and the s you know
what's the psychology and the rationale
behind that um
i'd love to just hear your you know
different perspectives
so my perspective is in the last
probably three
four years uh i really got i really
developed that thinking like don't put
all your eggs in one basket
so i was always having this side thing i
was either flipping stuff on ebay i was
doing walking tours i was doing videos
for companies
and it was all the time one salary
and then stuff on the side now
as you know but probably the audience
doesn't know but i am
planning to start my own things and then
when i said that to you you're
super supportive you're like oh man i
understand you know life has its seasons
you
those were your exact words life has its
seasons and
it's it's for me you know it depends if
if there's other videographer and
they're okay with the job like
okay you know they're just doing their
job but to me i feel it's
it i want to try to do it myself so
i don't know it's it's yeah so you
you're now you're now beginning to set
up um
your own company which we're like fully
behind um i don't think sometimes you
can
sometimes you can't you can't do like a
job like this
is so full on working for working for
the you know samuel is limited
so full-on trying to do different things
and stuff it's it's hard you can't
really
it's like a conflict sometimes um but at
the same time
if we've got someone in the office
that's like man i want to be an
entrepreneur i want to
we will encourage them to leave we'll be
like and a lot of people have
you know you're you're pro looking like
one one of those people there which is
great there's no problem
but i think employers that have um the
mindset of
trying to keep everybody called into
their kind like like
i've never been that way for me i'm
about releasing people sending people
off
um and i think that i think that's
really important i think it's an
important part of the culture of our
company
yeah i think the true boss is not being
a boss and dictating and giving commands
the true boss is working having a job as
working for the employees and i think
you are that type of person
yeah i i think i work as much for you as
you work for me like how i see it is
your um in fact gary vaynerchuk says
this which is brilliant gary vaynerchuk
talks about
how you're actually there to serve
your staff not the other way around
which i think is i think it's beautiful
because it's like
you know and look i'm not perfect and
i've got many mistakes and everything
but for me you know i think you should i
i'll regularly find myself asking
my staff how can i help what do you need
support with you know so i'm not
claiming to be the perfect
um the perfect leader or director or
anything like that but what's it like
generally what's it like working with
the team working with me so closely
because videographers are one of the few
people that get to work with me very
close
the accountants i mean we've got
full-time accountants admin
finance customer service they don't
speak to me very much
they can i'm here and i'll speak i'll
check in with them at times
but videographers every day like what's
it like working super closely with me
it was so funny i remember when i first
got your phone number i'm like i
went home to my girlfriend look i got
timeless number oh my god
it was crazy um and i i really enjoy it
i think you understand how important it
is to have you know good video
and all these things and that's why i
think you're working so close with
videographers
and i i really enjoy it i really enjoy
that makes me
you know brings me closer to you and
gives me
extra insights on how you're thinking so
for me it's great
the eviction yes
what happened with the eviction oh man
so let's because people wouldn't believe
it would they from from the beginning
i remember because uh as i told you i
like to do other things and
at that time you know and still doing
i'm teaching online how to do
videos you know people from around the
world and i remember
until the last moment because we
wouldn't are we going to go with it and
what i'm going to do and then
so the plan was we meet at the hotel
we're going to tell them
was it we we laid off for a week or we
cancel it or whatever we showed you
until next year
and we are in the car driving to the
airport and i see my schedule like the
next two days
you know i have two classes right and
i'm like samuel
is this counseling shall i shall i take
these classes
and you're like yeah i will cancel easy
i take the no problem
i take the classes we go to the venue
people are lining up they're coming up
people are coming up
where they're about to enter the room
and you're like no actually
let's do it let's do it now let's go
come on we can do that first challenge
now and we can
let's do it now and i'm like okay
cancel cancel i'm like
oh man that's so funny because what
happened was
we had the eviction i told 12 people
the month of november is the eviction
come on down first of november
and we'll start but then the day before
we went into a full national lockdown
i'm like
how are we gonna do the eviction during
a lockdown
we can make it happen all my advisors
you know everybody's like
samuel we forbid you from running the
eviction you have to cancel it you know
and i'm like okay well what am i going
to do
i know that people have come from like
david had come from ireland yeah
i can't just message everybody and say
it's cancelled so i thought what we'll
do is
we'll meet up everyone will come and
then i'll say to them look guys let's
all have a nice dinner
get some time unfortunately we're gonna
have to postpone it that's the plan
but then what happened was when i got
there and i saw everybody
and i saw how excited they were
and nervous and the and and peop that
people who
had left their jobs just to come on the
eviction
i was like nah we're gonna have to just
do it so we just
made a decision well i just made a
decision on the spot
guys guys come we had a little private
room i'm like we're
going ahead this month and everyone's
like but where is everyone going to
sleep and what about this
and and what about and amelia was like
but i've not packed anything what do you
mean we just
have to have a suitcase what do you mean
we're just doing the full-on eviction
for a whole month
right now we haven't got the equipment
we haven't got the the video we haven't
got the video
um we've only got this little crappy
little video camera that's why the
beginning the footage at the beginning
was a bit
[Music]
because i was just like let's just run
with it it's crazy
okay so um top tips then top three tips
for being a good videographer
um i think well videographer you work
with people you need to make them
feel nice you need to make them feel
nice yeah you need to feel them relax
because if you don't do that they were
like
what's happening so that's one then two
know your things
uh there is always something new to
learn with everything whenever
you think like okay i learn everything
you fail
yeah yeah and i think that's true i know
a third one
um okay i always say this to all my
videographers
and when someone new comes on like
darwin's is new and he was
shocked how i was telling him to do
things
less good okay right like he'd be doing
the thumbnail
so perfectionism yeah perfect yeah my my
philosophy is
done is better than perfect dan is the
new perfect
correct yeah you know just have to it's
really interesting though because
like don't use the new perfect yes
don't spend time making something
perfect just get it freaking out there
but at the same time sometimes i think
it does have to be done right depends on
what it is i understand what you mean
and when i started my videos i started
my youtube channel december 2016 and i
was like coming back to the videos and
okay add more tags more transitions
make it really nice but then i realized
that
it's nice for who you know you don't get
the to make the decision you know the
person is taking the decision maybe they
won't like it anyway
so i i started releasing more with less
being perfect but
you really switch my mind to be even
more that so yeah
just get it out i don't even see the
footage before it goes out
very rare unless it's a financial
freedom challenge or something where i'm
like i want to watch it because i'm
excited
or i might be involved um i might be
involved sometimes in in in
you know how we how we how we do it
because it's you know when you've got
40 hours of footage and you need to put
it down into half an hour it's like
no when you film everything that's what
happens yeah and it's like how do i know
what to put in what to leave out
and i'm really for me it's really
important that
people can follow the story you know
they get they see their
important things like like i'll say to
you if if it wasn't filmed it didn't
happen
like doing the financial freedom
challenge you know someone might say to
me during the eviction someone might say
to me oh we just had a deal and i'm like
was it filmed oh it wasn't filmed but we
did it i'm like wait it didn't happen
you know and i think i think you know
some things like that i'm quite bothered
about
um the eviction i'm like we need to film
this
we need to get everything captured but
then in terms of getting it perfect
you know it's an interesting one how how
involved will just how i am in the
actual
video production side of things
generally speaking i'm not talking about
necessarily
you know the the big um challenges or
the eviction
but just generally speaking day to day
would you say i'm very involved
not involved at all mediocre i would say
it depends every once in a while i think
it depends on the video i think depends
if uh
your agenda what things are happening on
your what happening with you but
sometimes you're even cancelling things
for videos because as i said you
understand how important that is
um as you said if you're bigger projects
you'll be more involved but
that's why you're working closely with
us with the videographer because you you
want to know
what's happening you you are on top of
things definitely you're on top of what
do you mean i'm cancelling things for
videos
i don't know if you have something if
you have something going on
but you think that the video is more
important you know
you pay more attention to the video yeah
well yeah because we we have to put out
video
every day every day we put a video out
on youtube
so it's hard work mental it is mental
also as well one of the things that some
of the guys said i don't know how you
feel about this but
it's like a lot of people come up to me
and they'll say hey you know your
youtube videos have changed my life
i've watched i've watched youtube videos
as a result i've got these properties
how does it feel being able to be the
person that actually edited those videos
it feels great every time i hear stuff
like that i'm like it's like you know
being that silent hero
because nobody knows you you're behind
camera you're editing videos and they're
praising the videos and they're best
praising you because you're on videos
fair point but you're the you know you
have a piece of little something
that you did over there and it's like ah
you've just changed my life and i'm
behind the camera like
yes yeah it feels nice it feels nice you
know what though
one of the things that i have is a lot
of hidden heroes around me
you know in every sector with my
properties
with my all my businesses my accountants
my surveyors my team
who aren't necessarily on and i'll say
when i do my training programs i'll be
like at the end i'll say look guys
um i'm actually have a business partner
russell's my business partner oh and
also amanda my wife
people people don't see a lot of stuff
that happens behind the scenes
um and i think i think that you know i'm
really grateful for people like you and
others the hidden heroes in in the team
um
also we've you know we've shed a lot
we've shared a lot of um close times
together even though it's been quite a
short time just a year and a half
you came out to uganda talk to me about
uganda um
it was really really an eye-opener for
me because i was with i really love
traveling
as i said i love charlie i love meeting
people i love filming all these and it's
i got this all these from this job
and thank you for bringing me to uganda
that was my
first african trip we were in the office
and everybody i remember everybody
wanted to go to uganda
and ralph said okay okay let's do that
everybody writes
on a piece of paper two names you know
two other people
and we just pick randomly and not pick
randomly but see who has the highest
score and i got a higher score
and i just like recently joined it just
as i joined within a month we went to
uganda
and you know because i was happy with
the financial freedom challenge how well
it went with filming-wise and all this
you were
happy for me to go to uganda it was
great and it was
it was really nice to see how people
were welcoming you because you were
already there and like oh thank you
for the things you've done you know they
were really happy
to see you so it was it was a good week
another thing as well is do you remember
on the way back
when um i said to you
you can either choose you can fly
business and sleep or
you can fly economy and we'll give you
500 quid
do you remember that i didn't get any
500 quid
did you know no what is this what
happened
well i don't know i fly economy
[Laughter]
did we not give you the choice no maybe
that was another story
you're going to invoice me now
thinking about sergey because i remember
you told me that you were offering him
massage
yeah i probably am thinking of sergio so
sergey
that's funny for you we didn't give we
just said flight equipment
i remember actually i remember what
happened with you with you you flew
economy
and i played business yeah but then we
bumped into
each other and i was like all right mate
all right
it was a bit awkward because even on the
way back on the way back and then
uh we checked in and you're like all
right uh
i'm gonna be the lounge over there
and i'm like okay i'll be here
have fun i'll see you in uganda cheerio
um but sergi we said to him because it
depends on the circumstances when we go
away
i mean it's it's it's you know it's
interesting
you know it's an interesting job set up
though yeah you know and and we try and
you know generally speaking i i i hope
normally i'm reasonably generous
um with different things but that was a
funny a funny instant but with sergi
i said to him after america you can come
with us
on business or you can go economy and
we'll give you 500 quid
oh now we were all
knackered like we needed to sleep i
think that was the difference i think
with sergi
i felt really bad for him because of how
tired we were at the end of the week
i was just thinking i couldn't do
economy it was a long flight
right we were knackered so i said look
man
normally when staff come out and stuff
they do fly
economy but because of how it's been
you can fly economy and we'll give you
500 quid
or you can come on business with us and
uh
he chose economy because he wanted the
500 quid but then he was
he had to have like two days off working
when he got back he was done
um i think that's what i said to you
though i think what i said to you is i
needed to work immediately when we got
back from uganda
we got back from uganda i need i'll get
that i'll get off the plane and i'll
work
yeah um so i'm like i need to sleep man
on the plane you had a couple days off
yeah oh yeah probably you did you did
if you didn't have your 500 quid you
definitely had a couple days off
anyway that's my justification and i'm
sticking with it
but no it was a great trip you know it
was a powerful trip
and um you know we we we visited a lot
of the works that we've done so with the
water tanks and the villages that we
that we'd helped um look into some of
the schools partnering with the
government
it was it was it was a really big
meeting so um what's plans what are the
plans for you then of the next over the
next year what's the plan set up your
business
yeah start a business uh start doing
getting more clients do videos for them
so it's all like events interviews
uh promo videos trailers everything
everything i even shot my first music
video i know
that was a raunchy video crazy that was
a really raunchy video
you do what the client wants right well
yeah i guess so hey dude well listen man
i'm i'm totally behind you in your
business
it's really strange interviewing
somebody we're not having a videographer
behind we should have probably got new
or amelia or someone in
but uh anyway dude hey if you like pav
he's an awesome guy
where's your website how can we get in
touch curious like i'm curious and in
parallel like my name curiouspower.com
or
any social network curious pavel curious
pavel p-a-v-e-l.com
yeah his book is on amazon called how to
talk to strangers top guy
appreciate you so much bro thank you for
all your hard work and uh yeah subscribe
to the channel
if not for me do it for pab peace out
see you next time
[Music]
you